[Música]
esta es la frontera detrás de nosotros y
eso es la frontera turca se llama
mohamed iker y trabaja como albañil en
gas en kiev en el sureste de turquía el
verano pasado este joven sirio intentó
cruzar la frontera entre turquía y
grecia para llegar a europa primero se
dirigió a la región de edirne en el
extremo occidental del país antes de
llegar a las orillas del río evros la
frontera natural entre turquía y grecia
pero allí fue agredido por los guardias
fronterizos griegos
en el primer intento los pasadores de
fronteras nos llevaron al otro lado del
río en una barca llegamos al lado griego
caminamos durante dos días pero el
ejército griego nos descubrió
nos detuvieron y al día siguiente nos
llevaron al río cuando llegamos a 100 o
150 metros del río el ejército nos
entregó a hombres encapuchados armados
con cuchillos y palos nos quitaron la
ropa nos golpearon y luego nos hicieron
cruzar el río nadando hasta turquía en
un lugar donde el agua no era muy
profunda
tres días después intenté cruzar el río
otra vez y de nuevo me detuvieron tres
soldados griegos me tiraron al suelo me
desvistieron y me dejaron en ropa
interior me golpearon durante dos a dos
horas y media
lo peor fue el golpe en la rodilla y
ahora estoy un poco mejor
las autoridades griegas niegan esta
práctica pero las devoluciones ilegales
a la frontera turca conocidas como push
back son frecuentes según las
organizaciones de defensa de los
derechos humanos
según la ong border violence el 98% de
las expulsiones van acompañadas de
torturas y malos tratos
diez días después cuando mi salud mejoró
implemente cobertura temporal
ayer cruzamos la frontera y dormimos
aquí acampamos aquí y esta noche vamos a
cruzar la carretera
interceptado por el ejército griego
mohamed fue golpeado de nuevo y enviado
a turquía dos veces más
publicó un largo vídeo en youtube para
contar la otra cara de su viaje el
denuncia que los llamados pasadores
prometen un cruce de fronteras sin
problemas hay mujeres familias con niños
que intentan hacer el viaje muchas
personas si supieran todo lo que sucede
no lo harían lo grippo a tanta gente y
entrar cruzar la frontera son los
pasadores que promueven estos viajes a
través de grupos de facebook de hecho de
cada 100 personas que lo intentan cada
día sólo 5 lo logras estos grupos de
pasadores hacen vídeos promocionales de
las 5 personas que lo consiguen llegamos
a tesalónica y luego a ti sin pasadores
pero entre las 95 personas que no lo
logran hay muertos heridos desaparecidos
si uno no lo logra y decide mirar sonido
estos grupos de djs surgió telegraph se
enfadan mucho y se niegan a publicarlo
así que francamente hay mucha gente
viene
cada año cientos de migrantes se ahogan
en el río evros en este cementerio
situado en sido un pequeño pueblo griego
a pocos kilómetros de la frontera con
turquía están enterrados cerca de 200
migrantes no identificados
está pensando en renunciar a su trabajo
en este momento dar muchos de nosotros
que estamos pensando así que hablemos de
eso
una hora antes de renunciar
hoy fue mi último día en la empresa
estoy saliendo del edificio de hotel
desde la primavera boreal más de 20
millones de personas han renunciado a
sus trabajos en eeuu un récord histórico
muchos de ellos han comentado o
publicado en redes sociales sus últimos
momentos en sus empresas este movimiento
que ya ha sorprendido a muchos jefes y
supervisores es llamado la gran renuncia
nuestra observadora precisamente
renunció a su trabajo el pasado mes de
agosto y nos explica sus motivos tenía
un trabajo en el que iba a la oficina
todos los días pasaba dos horas en el
transporte público y luego llegó el cob
y empecé a trabajar desde casa y me
encanta trabajar desde casa entonces
cuando mi antiguo empresa me dijo que
era el momento de volver a trabajar de
volver a la oficina pensé no lo creo así
que renuncie y empecé a trabajar en una
empresa que me permite dele a trabajar
al 100% de acuerdo todo es la fecha
oficial de regreso a la oficina es el 15
de julio
o están emocionados
renuncio cuando la gente estaba
confinada y trabajaba desde casa
cuarentena al principio de la pandemia
muchos perdieron sus trabajos porque la
producción tuvo que realizarse pero
ahora va en el sentido contrario la
producción se está recuperando la gente
está volviendo a trabajar y no está
volviendo a los mismos trabajos que
tenían antes
señor otras diez personas presentaron
sus cartas de renuncia cuál es el
problema los salarios bajos las largas
jornadas y el estrés adicional de
trabajar durante la pandemia sí pero
también que la gente está descubriendo
lo que realmente quiere hacer con su
vida lo que realmente quiere hacer con
su vida creo que mucha gente se está
dando cuenta con el joven que la vida es
preciosa la vida es corta
quieren darle prioridad a su vida por
encima de su trabajo
veo a mucha gente haciendo vídeos en
trenton sobre cómo se han dado cuenta de
que tienen algo que ofrecer en su
búsqueda de empleo que no se sienten tan
desesperados por aceptar el primer
trabajo que les da una empresa pagar el
salario mínimo ya no es suficiente
no va a traer nuevos trabajadores hay
que hacer que merezca la pena renunciar
a una parte de la vida de uno para
trabajar para una empresa me da
curiosidad ver cuánto durará esto este
movimiento masivo de renuncias también
se está produciendo en varios países
europeos pero en los países en vías de
desarrollo la situación no es la misma
en américa latina y el caribe 26
millones de personas perdieron sus
empleos como consecuencia de la pandemia
de kobe 19 eso es todo por esta semana
en los observadores de france 24 para
entrar en contacto con nuestra redacción
para compartir con nosotros sus
fotografías videos y contarnos sus
historias pueden hacerlo a través de
twitter whatsapp o correo electrónico
los contactos aparecen en sus pantallas
nos vemos la próxima semana hasta pronto